good morning John so I have a head cold
which I would complain about except that
you just got out from the hospital
because you have viral meningitis when
is maybe a little bit worse than cold uh
so I feel like I should suck it up and
just do my best to entertain you make
you feel better while your head is
trying to fall off of your body so
here's a monkey selfie mad cute monkey
his picture was taken when photographer
David Slater's camera was stolen by a
rare crested black macaque macaque then
proceeded to take lots and lots of
pictures of itself of other macaques of
just the leaves most of them were
terrible like anybody with a DSLR this
one was very good and not only because
the macaque has the beautiful smile on
its face and he's in focus and there's a
nice depth of field thing going on good
composition that's because the idea of
selfies has sort of permutated culture
and is now a thing and the idea of a
monkey taking a selfie is kind of silly
and funny and people want to put that on
their blogs all this is combined into
this becoming David Slater's most famous
photograph ever most successful
photograph ever at least by some
measures some is that David Slater makes
his living by selling photographs but
this picture has been declared by the
Wikimedia Foundation as being in the
public domain meaning it's free for
everyone to use why this is David
Slater's photograph he should have the
ability to sell it well he didn't take
it it was taken by a monkey and monkeys
at least so far are not legally able to
own things anything including
intellectual property this is
unfortunate for David Slater who carried
lots of very heavy and expensive
equipment a very long way to get this
autograph but it seems to me like the
Wikimedia Foundation zarg youment makes
sense it's everybody's photo which is
why I can use it in this video because
macaques
can't own stuff anyhow viral meningitis
whoa huh if you're confused John who is
the other half of this video blog if
you're very confused as my brother and
he got viral meningitis last week he's
home from the hospital now he's fine
though he is still in a significant
amount of pain this has resulted in a
first ever of all time thing on
vlogbrothers I have three videos in a
row on this channel because after day
happened as well and John missed a video
so now wow it's like the Hank show I
don't like it please John come back
because I don't know what to talk about
without riffing off of you Jonah's now
missed three videos because of
hospitalizations once for his orbital
cellulitis when his the back of his
eyeball got infected once for his
gallbladder being removed and now for
viral meningitis stop John stop that
first time John missed his video when he
had the orbital cellulitis the eye
infection we banded together and we made
a nice video to help him feel better
well people put stuff on their heads for
him because putting stuff on your head
is funny and it makes people feel better
it's a well-known scientific fact
there's journal articles all about it
who thought to do it again and in the
spirit of questionable copyright I'm
gonna do it with a help my friend Calvin
in Paris meningitis is of dharma when
you're in starts to pound
stepheson neck and sensitivity to sound
rising pressure in your cranium
your blood pressure down you bring it
stop the oxygen now but you will rebound
meningitis is a bummer
John I really really really really
really hope that I'll see you on Tuesday
ah because I don't want to do this by
myself anymore it's not bought brother